what up space fam golden here from anime
upper back at it again to discuss yet
another hype demonstrator character the
strongest upper moon and user of the
moon breathing style himself kokushibo i
said i'd get started on this one or the
upper moon 2 doma one if genya got over
6500 likes and at this point it has way
more than that so time to discuss
kokushibo there were plenty requests for
both kokushimo and doma and i decided to
go with kokoshibo first but never fear
doma fans if we can hit over 6500 likes
on this one i repeat
6500 then i'll get started on the doma
video asap feel free to drop suggestions
for future demonstrator videos in the
comments as well if you haven't make
this the video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss your
regular dose of demonstrator content and
lastly as you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all the hashira all the demon
moons like 20 other how strong is
demonstrator videos and much more link
to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all kokushibo's full
appearance debuts during chapter 99 and
immediately he has quite the
intimidating aura around him after upper
moon 3 akaza takes off upper moon 2
doma's head his arm quickly gets sliced
off to his shock it is kokushibo who
tells him that he goes too far akasa is
willing to mess with dolma but even he
is struck by the presence and power
kokushibo and obeys him kokushibo makes
it clear that he doesn't care about doma
but he does care about disturbing the
hierarchy of the rankings and tells him
to request blood combat if he wishes to
replace dolma or himself doma says akasa
would never win against him but this
time akaza doesn't let his irritation
lead to violence in front of upper moon
1. kokushibo asks if akas understands
him and akuza replies he does understand
notably the very strong doma also calls
him lord kokushibo showing that he gets
a lot of respect from even the second
strongest demon moon it's revealed in
the second demon slayer fan book that
kokushiba was challenged three times for
his upper moon one position he would
usually absorb the demons he defeated
but when akaza challenged him and lost
to him he spared him because he enjoyed
the challenge now let's fast forward to
kokushibo's fight against muichiro genya
sanemi and gyome the strongest hashira
because it's the best example of what
he's actually capable of muichiro is the
first to run into him we see at this
point that kokoshibo has access to the
see-through world a powerful ability
that can only be unlocked by especially
skilled demon slayers that have awakened
their demon's layer mark long story
short it allows one to see the muscles
blood flow and so on of a person
allowing you to better predict their
movements it's a form of hyper
perception where the world starts to
feel like it's moving in slow motion
giving the demon slayer more time to
react the strongest demon stares utilize
this ability and the fact that kukushibo
can use it is a testament to his skill
and power back to muichiro and
kokoshibo's first encounter just as
akaza felt kokushibo's aura so did
muichiro muichiro states that he can't
be compared to any of the other upper
moons he's profound and majestic for the
first time in his life muichiro's body
won't stop shaking and it's telling him
that it doesn't want to fight although
only 14 muichiro has always been
considered one of the best most talented
hashira tangen viewed him and gomei as
the most gifted and talented he also had
the honor of defeating an upper moon all
by himself after he awakened his demons
player marks so this kind of reaction
from someone as strong as muichiro
should not be glossed over the two talk
a bit and it is revealed that muichiro
is actually a descendant of kukushibo
which further hypes up kokushibo for
having especially talented genes even
before his demon transformation
kokushibo also reveals that his name was
michikatsu tsugikuni when he was a human
muichiro goes on to calm himself in
attack and it's clear from the bat that
kokushibo completely outclasses him the
upper moon is patronizing complementing
his moves while easily avoiding them
finally kokoshibo decides to draw his
sword so as not to be rude and
immediately uses his moon breathing to
slice off the arm of awakened demon sir
mark muichiro thus not only is kokoshibo
a strong demon he combines that with
being a skilled breath style user and
swordsman muichiro can't help but remark
that kokushibo's speed is phenomenal
kokushibo makes quick work of muichiro
by pinning him to a beam with muichiro's
own sword he could finish him off but he
decides to have muzon turn his
descendant into a demon so he lets him
live for the time being kenya then shows
up and fires off a shot from a shotgun
only for kokoshibo to immediately close
the distance between them and cut off
his arm too he goes on to cut off the
other and even bisects his body as he's
about to finish genya off by slicing off
his head big bro's sun enemy comes to
the rescue and saves his little brother
again sanemi kokoshibo draws his blade
in order to block sonomy's attacks and
reveals a very disgusting sword to use
tsunami's words it is made of his flesh
and has a bunch of eyes on it as if the
six on his head weren't enough despite
how ugly it is there are many benefits
to a sword made out of demon flesh as
we'll see in a bit sudimi explains
kokoshibo's blood demon arc magnified
moon breathing style as follows
kokoshibo makes an irregular and complex
array of crescent blades spring from a
single slashing attack their length and
size always change so they don't have
fixed forms thus it's not just about
dodging one slash but you also have to
avoid the countless and unpredictable
crescent blades as well sun emi admits
to himself that he couldn't survive as
long as he did if his senses hadn't been
honed from long experience experience
that muichiro just didn't have sanemi
also points out how kokushibo is using
breathing to further increase his
already insane demon speed and striking
power the wind hashira does very well
for a while and kokoshibo thinks about
how sonemy being able to keep up with
his techniques makes him nostalgic and
want to try harder however kokushibo
does get the upper hand with his attack
moon breathing sixth form perpetual
knight lonely moon incessant the wild
barrage of countless crescent moon
blades not only cuts up sun enemy but
also far away beams the long-range
nature of kokushibo's crescent blade
slashes makes him extremely op if sun
emi weren't sun enemy he'd be done
kokushibo can see his internal damage by
accessing the transparent world and
notes that if he moves sonemy's entrails
will spill out not only does sanami
appear to stop the bleeding by
coagulating his blood with breathing and
flex his muscles to stop his guts from
spilling out he also has one of the
rarest blood types that makes it
extremely intoxicating to demons and
makes them lose focus this is one of the
reasons why sanomi cut himself in front
of nezuko and so it was all the more
impressive that she was able to resist
attacking him the marechi as it's called
makes kokushibo experience slight
drunkenness but it doesn't slow him down
enough to make a real difference luckily
gyome the strongest hotshot shows up as
backup before sunemi can be finished gyo
may give sanemi time to stitch up his
wounds and in the meantime kokoshibo
notices that gyome has the perfect
physical form developed to the utmost
kokushibo thinks it's been at least 300
years since he's seen such a great
swordsman gyomi goes on to impress
kokoshibo even noticed that trying to
cut gilmay's ball axe and chain weapon
is pointless because his flesh sword
would only break the iron used to make
gyome's weapons has absorbed an insane
amount of sunlight making it all the
more powerful against demons iron that
has absorbed that much sunlight hadn't
even been discovered in the sengoku
period when swordsmithing was at its
peak we're told kokoshibo goes on to
call gyomay unbelievable because of the
way he's able to use his very heavy
weapon with so much likeness and agility
as if it were an extension of his own
body not only does kokoshibo look like
he's on the defensive for a while gyome
even succeeds in breaking his flesh
sword yeah it does regenerate which is a
huge strength of the flesh sword but
it's important not to underestimate this
detail kokushibo is a very prideful dude
and he wouldn't willingly let someone
break his sword they'd have to actually
be good enough to do it so even before
he activates his demonstra mark which he
was saving for muzon gyome gets further
than anyone we saw before against
kokushibo which includes two of the
other most talented hashira muichiro and
sanemy when gyome finally realizes he
needs to activate his demonstrator mark
in order to have a chance of winning
kokoshibo actually says too bad since
gyome is about 27 years old he's
probably going to die soon since as
kokushibo states the marked ones die
before they reach the age of 25. he says
there are no exceptions but obviously
yorichi the strongest demonstrator was
an exception and he knows that even if
he's not saying it still it does seem
like bad news for gyome as the mark
almost always significantly reduces a
demon slayer's lifespan kokushibo
estimates that gyome will die tonight
because he's already past 25 and he's
actually sad that gomes body and
technique that have been developed to
the utmost will disappear from this
world gyome who is so awesome for saying
this answers that he doesn't think it's
lamentable and that the marked ones
already understand that and mark or no
mark there is no guarantee for a
demonstrator that they will live to
tomorrow hashida are always ready for
death and it's an insult to even suggest
that they'd cling to life with
half-hearted determination despite the
awakening of the strongest hashida's
marks kokushibo is notably still not
worried in fact he wishes for gyoume to
keep on living and even wants him to
become a demon clearly this dude is
still very confident and unshaken when
it comes to his belief in his abilities
and acting like that in front of the
strongest hashira who has just awakened
his demonstra mark is undeniably
impressive however what does shay
kokushibo is when gyome senses that
there was an exception to the no one
lives past 25 rule when gyome says it he
notices that it shakes
reaffirming that he's right yorichi the
brother of kokoshibo and the strongest
demons there in history was the
exception and clearly bringing him up
shakes up kokushibo just like it does
muzon more on yurichi in relation to
kokushibo later though the fight
continues and though kokoshibo is
arguably stronger a mark gyome does
succeed in hanging on until a marked
tsunami can join in the reason why it's
clear that kokoshibo is stronger than a
marked gyome is because even after
sanemi comes in to help they can't beat
him at least not with just the two of
them and this is very impressive too
because not only are these two arguably
the two strongest hashira at this point
but they've trained together so in a
battle of speed they can cooperate
really well kokoshibo says it himself
that perhaps these two are highly
skilled even among the hashira notably
he does say especially gyomei since he
notices a clear difference in their
levels nonetheless kokoshibo states that
sunemi is getting faster and more
accurate together the two hashira
succeed in cutting off kokoshibo's ear
now yes this is nothing for a demon who
can easily regrow a leg or arm but it's
the first time they took something off
of his body proper last time it was just
his sword thus this is a sign to us that
this is the closest they've been to
reaching kokoshibo's level so far they
have been improving and using their
collective skills to close the gap
somewhat since kokushibo is a prideful
swordsman he's not like other demons
whether he admits it or not kokushibo
doesn't like the idea of people slicing
off parts of his body because it may
reflect a lack of kokushibo's
swordsmanship skills and strength as a
swordsman they continue to push
kokushibo until he is forced to evolve
his sword if you will he makes it larger
and adds some side blades to increase
its reach he gets significant slashes on
gyome and tsunemi this way catching them
off guard you can tell kokoshibo's upset
when he says that they merely managed to
shred his kimono and that that's not
even enough to kill an infant even
though he's a demon and shouldn't really
look at how the wounds given to him
would affect humans he clearly does this
is another clue that he clearly doesn't
want to get wounds that would kill a
human because of his pride even though
they obviously wouldn't kill him as a
demon it's a sign that kokoshibo hasn't
been going all out but rather has been
fighting while trying to avoid all body
wounds it shows that he's got strength
to spare which is a big deal when you're
already doing so well against the two
strongest hashira from kokushibo's
surprise attack senemy loses some
fingers and thinks about how he was
barely able to respond gyome actually
saved him by using his chain to alter
the angle of attack if not for gyome's
insane level of strength and skill
senemy would have lost both of his arms
thus tsunami although very strong is
clearly outmatched by gyome and
kokoshibo sonome even remarks that he's
getting slower the more damage he takes
he's holding gyome back and his marechi
is barely working at all anymore even
though it's supposed to work precisely
on stronger demons it definitely looks
like kokoshibo is too strong for sanmi
and gyome at this point however muichiro
and genya are still in the area so
there's still hope the fight continues
and gyome remarks that kokoshibo is
getting stronger not weaker his attack
range more than doubled and his speed is
insane to the point where gyome has to
think to himself this is bad sanemy is
using all his strength just to dodge and
keeps getting sliced he ends up telling
gyomay to forget about him but muichiro
eventually comes in and saves sanemi
from an attack that would have finished
him off in the meantime genya has been
eating parts of kokushibo like his hair
and broken off sword flesh and as a
result gaining demon powers kirby's
style as kokushibo is using a 16th form
gyome sings his praises even more he
mentions kokoshibo is not running out of
techniques and he's too fast gyome can't
even attack because kokoshibo predicts
his every move pretty much it's
kokushibo's access to the transparent
world that's allowing him to predict his
moves so quickly finally being pushed to
his limits gyome breaks through and also
unlocks access to the transparent world
gyoume is blind but he can still use his
other senses to reach it at this point
kokoshibo is taking on three of the most
talented marked hashrat at the same time
and eventually thanks to gyome launching
a bead from his rosary and hitting
kokushibo's hand they catch him off
guard and they take off his entire demon
arm and part of his chest not only that
muichiro also succeeds in getting close
enough to stab him and keep in mind
muichiro is accessing the transparent
world at this point too it's at this
point kokoshibo realizes that gyome
started to see the transparent world as
well and actually used it to deceive
kokoshibo's eyes by controlling his own
blood circulation in order to disturb
kokushibo's attack it may sound a bit
complicated but it boils down to gyome
is insanely talented and thanks to him
the three hashira succeeded in getting a
hit on kokushibo that would be a big
deal even a mortal wound to a human
swordsman you could say the three
together keyword together proved to be
better swordsman than kokoshibo alone
but at the same time it must be kept in
mind that all three of them and soon
genya will join in too are taking on one
kokushibo thus although kokoshibo would
have preferred not to have to use demon
regeneration it seems justified in a
sense since they are all teaming up on
him so in his mind kokushibo's probably
becoming a bit less concerned with
resorting to his demon superpowers and
the superhuman demon powers are part of
what we have to consider while analyzing
kokushibo's full strength kokushibo
notes that several unexpected things
have happened that let these guys get
these good hits on him but still no one
reached his neck this is when genya
comes into play i break down his
abilities in more detail in my how
strong is genya video but what's
important is that he gained a big power
up through the consumption of
kokoshibo's flesh he even has his own
kokushibo like demonstrator mark now his
gun now covered in kokushibo-like eyes
lets him fire bullets that he can
telepathically control thus even though
kokoshibo is skilled enough to block
them they end up turning like living
things and going into his skin anyways
the bullets sprout into trees and roots
trapping kokushibo it is at this point
with three of the strongest hashida
fighting him and a new overpowered blood
demon art from genya that kokoshibo
finally feels threatened as he says and
i quote this sensation of my composure
crumbling up from my feet is detestable
it brings back memories from 400 years
ago end quote and then he goes into the
memory of him and his more talented
brother yorichi thus it took all four of
these fighters for him just to begin
losing his composure which is definitely
very impressive we can assume that
kokushibo is more powerful in the
present than he was in the flashback
since he had 400 years to consume more
people which is how demons are supposed
to get even stronger however it's
notable that during the time of the
flashback an old yarichi probably past
80 years old was a lot stronger than the
demon-enhanced kokushibo despite being
so old he was said to be as strong as he
was in his prime and kokoshibo couldn't
even react quick enough to dodge his
attacks kokushibo knew after the first
attack that the next attack would finish
him off but then yorice passed away
standing up our boy just died of old age
right there i love yurichi and it's no
surprise that kokoshibo stood no chance
against him because even muzon got
wrecked by him on a side note yorichi is
the one that had a demonstra mark and
lived well past 25 which is why we can't
assume that tanjiro who had a demon star
mark would automatically die by age 25
after the muslim battle i saw some
people asking me about this detail in
the comments but yeah there is reason to
believe and hope that tundra could have
lived to old age along with his unmarked
friends but anyways back to kokoshibo it
is at this point that kokoshibo starts
mentally crumbling as he mentioned he
thinks to himself after getting
embarrassed by urichi's godly skill and
i quote i chose to continue winning
until i became ugly like this end quote
so clearly this isn't a dude who is
comfortable with what he's become and is
second guessing his life choices i
believe that this self-doubt as with
akaza's fight against tundra and giu
will play a part in kokoshibo's eventual
downfall but i'm getting ahead of myself
kokoshibo unleashes a bunch of blades
from his body and it not only slices up
the roots but also the demon slayers
genya gets bisected vertically this time
while muichiro gets bisected
horizontally and sanemi and gyo may get
hurt but nothing as serious as the other
two muichiro the mad lad keeps holding
on to his sword that's still inside
kokoshibo with only his upper body left
at this point kokoshibo sort of looks
like a christmas tree with blades coming
out all over his body he has clearly
given up on just fighting as a swordsman
and resorted to all of his demonic ugly
powers and you know he hates himself for
it it is at this point that muichiro
turns his blade red another power-up for
demon slayers one that comes even after
the mark the red blade is super
effective against demons and kokoshibo
starts feeling like his insides are on
fire then genya who like muichiro is
about to pass away activates some of the
remaining flesh bullets still in
kokoshibo the combination of the
redblade and the sprouted flesh bullets
prevent kokoshibo from using his
technique the tree is sucking up his
blood which probably interferes with him
using his blood demon art effectively
and his body is also seizing up from the
intense pain of muijiro's red katana
then gyome's spiked ball lands a
kokushibo's head and even this is not
enough to finish him sunimi needs to
slam down on the ball with his blade
both weapons turn red like muichiro's
and finally kokoshibo's head comes off
if that was it if kokoshibo died right
there that would still be insanely
impressive that it took so much to beat
him but shockingly he's not finished yet
kokushibo points out that muichiro even
cut in half he didn't let go of his
katana kenya was a human able to use a
blood demon art sun enemy wouldn't die
no matter how many times she was cut up
and gyome's speed of growth was
comparable to a demons and he surpassed
his own limits all of these already
strong fighters got stronger than
they've ever been throughout this fight
with their marks access to the
transparent world and red blades they
all surpassed their past limits in their
own way and that's what made this such a
satisfying fight up to this point gyome
and tsunami noticed though that the
fight isn't over yet when kokoshibo
stops bleeding they continue their
onslaught of attacks kokushibo realizes
that his body isn't falling apart
despite losing his head and if he pulls
out the red sword and roots he can still
regenerate and if you didn't know if a
demon overcomes getting decapitated by
nutrient blades which is possible
although muzon and almost akaza are the
only known examples of it happening up
to this point then the demon pretty much
becomes invincible except for the sun
and since they are in another dimension
with no sun kokushibo would pretty much
be invincible if he pulled off this
regeneration the only way he could be
stopped if that were to happen is if
muzon killed him or if they somehow
dragged him out of the dimension and
back into the sun of the real world and
kokushibo shockingly proceeds to
actually grow his head back and wow he's
never looked so monstrous he thinks to
himself he overcame it and now any kind
of attack other than sunlight is
meaningless but that's when he catches
his reflection on sonomy's blade and
sees the monster he's become in remarks
on how ugly it looks not even
recognizing the image as himself the
doubts i mentioned before resurface he
asks himself and i quote is this how a
samurai looks end quote which was what
he wanted to be when he was growing up
he asks is this really what i wanted and
that's when his body starts to crumble
from where muichiro stabbed him and
although a part of him wants to use the
technique even though he can't another
part of him is clearly not sure what he
wants anymore this part is open to
interpretation does kokoshibo die
because he would have died anyways or
was it his mental collapse that
triggered his physical deterioration i
personally feel like the timing was too
convenient and since he started
crumbling after he saw his reflection
and after his doubts rushed in it was at
least in part because of his mental
breakdown he no longer had that pure
will to keep on living whatever the cost
and so one could argue that even at this
point kukushibo could have survived and
become immortal if he 100 percent wanted
to and like i mentioned a part of him
was trying to regenerate and keep
fighting but i think there were
competing parts of him that wanted
different things and the pulling from
different directions is what allowed
sanomi and gyomei to finish off his body
kokoshibo mentions himself the ugliness
of not admitting defeat even though they
took off his head those are not the
words of someone who just wants to
survive at all costs anymore as he says
he equates surviving now with living in
disgrace and that doesn't sound like
something a wannabe samurai would want
to do in fact seppuku originated with
japan's ancient samurai warrior class as
a means to achieve an honorable death so
living in disgrace is just the furthest
thing you could be from an ideal samurai
and that realization that kokoshibo
strayed so far from being a samurai like
he always wanted to be and became a
monster instead was part of the reason
kokoshibo didn't regenerate in my view
thus when talking about how strong
kokoshibo is we should at least consider
the possibility that he could have been
one of those invincible demons that even
gyome saneme muichiro and genya together
would not have been able to defeat
without the help of the sun i believe if
kokushibo was like muzon personality
wise he would have regrown his head but
he never truly let go of the past of
wanting to be an honorable samurai of
his brother which is symbolized by the
fact that he kept the flute that he gave
yorichi when they were kids right up
until the end unlike muzon kokushibo
couldn't completely abandon his humanity
and that's why he started crumbling away
suddenly rather than achieving
invincible status but yeah that is it
for what we know about kokoshibo's
strength he was the strongest upper moon
when he fought against gyomay and the
rest at that time he could have beaten
any individual slayer alive including
youme however gyome sanemi muichiro and
genya three of the strongest hashira and
a slayer who absorbed some of
kokoshibo's own power worked together
well enough and evolved over the course
of the battle enough to take off his
head even then he succeeded in regrowing
his head until he saw the monstrous
reflection in sonomy's sword and only
then as his doubts came rushing in did
he begin to crumble away from where
muichiro his descendant stabbed him
muzon the demon king of pop of course
was stronger than kokoshibo and so was
yorichi although kokoshibo must have
gone stronger since his confrontation
with yorichi 400 years ago it has made
clear that he never reached shirichi's
godly level and that is it for this
video i hope you appreciated it
especially since this one did end up
taking more time than i expected if you
did enjoy it it would be awesome if you
could channel the orichi within and
smash that like button let me know what
you think of kokoshibo as a character
and who is your favorite upper moon
remember smashing that like button is
yorichi energy and passing his muzon
energy so choose wisely and if we can
hit 6500 likes on this one then i'll get
started on the upper moon to doma video
asap let me know in the comments what
you think of kokoshibo who is your
favorite upper moon feel free to leave
suggestions in the comments for future
demonstrator videos too if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss your
regular dose of demonstrator content and
lastly as you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all the hashira all the demon
moons like 20 other how strong is
demonstrated videos and much more link
to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord wigo himself alpha
sigma and or the one tier patrons the
ones who stay on top all clans ingrata
al-jatal pate hepa the red-haired fox
hinokami and water the toasted tree
corey mcgowan the spike lonely dakar
dylan isadore spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis big buddhist jeremy cummings and
che a whitley and our pro here to your
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews very gucci alicia
actor bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy
games kylo might be a duck jessica
rabbit jeremy phillips ali baitnia and
temple thank you all so much if you do
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon.com anime
upper and becoming a patron today for as
little as one dollar if you do so your
name feature in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course thank meme so
check out
patreon.com link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]
so
[Music]
you